powerful voice throughout this entire
process texas senator ted cruz's with a
senator good to see you I applaud your
colleagues I applaud you the entire time
I'm a little bewildered why we have to
wait till Wednesday be honest but I
guess we now know of what what will
happen by then well Shawn that's exactly
right I think the last 24 hours were
pivotal for all intents and purposes
this this impeachment process is is over
the vote we had today not to extend the
trial not to have yet more additional
witnesses we already had 18 witnesses
testify in the house we've seen
thousands of pages of documents that
that the house managers and the White
House defense lawyers have focused on
and and throughout all of it the house
managers never proved their case and and
so their strategy as you know was just a
Hail Mary if they haven't proven their
case their only hope was bring
additional witnesses drag it out weeks
or months and go on a fishing expedition
hope that somebody said something that
would give them some basis for
impeachment because they haven't proven
it and and and this was a vote for
Republicans were right on the edge and
and today holding 51 in the majority to
say we're done we've got enough this is
over that means we're headed straight to
Wednesday afternoon a vote on final
judgment and the president is going to
be acquitted of these charges as he
should be and and you had I know now the
congenital liar you had Jerry Nadler
that they kept repeating we have so
proven our case beyond any reasonable
doubt I want to stick to the
constitutional aspects of this now
professor Dershowitz did say you were
one of his best students and he's going
to join us on set here in a little bit
but but there are constitutional
concerns here the power constitutionally
the sole power to impeach that lies with
the house the sole power for the trial
lies with the Senate yeah I could not
understand the argument if they totally
completely proved their case beyond any
reasonable doubt and and the case is a
slam dunk case why they were trying to
get your body the United States Senate
to take on the constitutional role of
the house when they rushed it through so
urgently so they could go on vacation
and then hold it back from the Senate
for so long well look I'll return the
compliment on alan dershowitz he was my
professor in law school was a phenomena
fact he was my professor in criminal law
101 the very first week of law school
and what was an amazing teacher and I
think his presentation to the Senate was
one of the most impactful presentations
of the entire trial and in particular he
walked through the history of what the
Constitution requires this is not just a
vote on whether you like the president
or not whether you agree with the
president or not whether your politics
are the same this is a vote over whether
the constitutional standard is met and
the Constitution says for impeachment
that the only grounds for impeachment
are treason bribery or other high crimes
and misdemeanors and what professor
Dershowitz walked through very
effectively and actually before him what
Ken Starr walked through very
effectively is that the constitutional
threshold requires a grave serious crime
of the level of treason or bribery
House managers didn't even try to allege
a crime and and they certainly didn't
prove one and and and that's why as a
matter of law and and by the way we did
this whole digression on quid pro quo
and all the discussion about additional
witnesses for whether there was a quid
pro quo whether there wasn't a quid pro
quo as a matter of law it didn't matter
it was a side diversion that was one of
the things we clarified during the
questioning period that I think was
really critical to getting the four
votes to end to not have additional
witnesses it is that we asked actually
Lindsey Graham and I together wrote the
question asking even if you assume for
sake of argument that that that there
was a quid pro quo does that change the
legal analysis is this a high crime or
misdemeanor and the president's lawyers
answered exactly right that even if
there were a quid pro quo
you got disputed testimony on that it
doesn't matter because the president has
the authority to investigate corruption
and there was more than sufficient
evidence of potential corruption with
burry smih and the Biden's for the
President to ask for an investigation on
it and there was also evidence that yet
we know from a Ukrainian court we know
from an investigative report in Politico
on election interference last question
senator
did you get an A in professor Dershowitz
his class well you know it's an
interesting story first class criminal I
didn't I got a B+ in his first class I
took a second class from him called
thinking about thinking that that was
co-taught with him and Stephen Jay Gould
and Robert Nozick world famous
philosopher and and I did get an A+ in
that one so so you can average those two
A+ Wow okay so that averages out to an a
B plus a plus all right senator you did
great work you you educated the public
thank you for your your duty basically
some people need to learn what is in the
Constitution